I'm ready are you ready how do I let me
get these left so
oh my gosh
okay you're gonna be fine are you gonna
cut out like Aqua seeds yes if you make
a mistake or laugh or whatever I'll just
take it out okay do I look decent you
look more than decent darling you're one
of the prettiest girls I've ever done oh
thank you you are one of the prettiest
girls Shadow told me this like this I
used to I always ask him to send a photo
first and he goes you don't need a photo
on this one trust me on this this is one
of the prettiest ones I've ever sent and
he sent me some gorgeous girls thank you
so you're you're I know Exotics is
really pretty too yeah she's beautiful
too but there's even prettier girls than
her oh wow yeah yeah you're right up
there with the top three thank you I've
done like four or five hundred so damn
oh my God yeah you're pretty gorgeous
okay are you recording I'm I'm trying
I'm going to edit out this part okay
I'll just ask you questions
okay
okay well I feel better knowing that the
awkward [__] you cut out I'll take
everything out yeah if if you stumble on
something or say a word wrong or
whatever I'll just take it out okay so
don't worry about that
all right cat
wait can I see my phone
I just want to make sure I look good in
the camera I am so sorry
thank you
okay
yeah I'm ready I'll charge it for him
oh I wanted to keep it on me okay
okay all right cat
oh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I'm from Missouri what
part of Missouri Kansas City yeah
tell me about your family growing up
yeah both your parents
um I have my dad
where was Mom
I don't know
you never had your mom
um
how would you describe your childhood
with your father pretty normal
there were no female
yeah yeah
stepmom okay
how would you describe your childhood in
general
and crazy went on no abuse nothing like
that no
we're kind of kid were you in high
school
um
this quiet
you graduated
no
so you've been doing sex work since when
for like eight months are you pretty new
with us
I wouldn't say that's new
how'd you get introduced to it I always
wanted to do this you always wanted to
do it since what age
since I was like 15.
where'd you first see it
um I don't remember I don't I just
always like I wrote in my diary I wanted
to do this
really and then my parents found a yeah
wow you uh
you find a pimp to help you with that do
you get into the game
and uh was your experience been since
you've been doing it
um
it is bad better now is it what you
thought it was getting into it
how is it different than what your idea
your fantasy was of what it would be
like
um I I just thought like I'll get beat
all the time and [__] like that but it's
not like that no
because I was like Frosty and all that
are you making money
so you moved to LA when how long you
been here like a month ago
I see you're fairly new here too well I
grew up coming here like because I have
like some family out here oh your family
so I grew up coming here like during the
summer you work in Figueroa Street
I just started working fake a month ago
yeah
which is like the biggest
sex playground in the U.S probably
I don't know I just started doing the
blade stuff I was doing the internet I
started off being on the internet like
posting ads
and are drugs a part of your life
only we just weed
what you say is the hardest part of this
this life lifestyle for you
Cali just like
um the danger I guess yeah it's
dangerous for sure yeah that's it though
have you had bad things happen to you
only once I got beat up and then that's
it I never had another bad experience
you get arrested you get hassled by the
cops at all I got arrested once
tell me about the guys who are your
customers
the tricks
um what do you mean like are they like
on Figaro Street there there's a lot of
Mexicans
you probably get picked by white guys as
well
um everything everything
it depends like fig a lot of Mexicans
but I work Hollywood too so like a lot
of Asian dudes Armenians when I work in
Hollywood
what's your favorite kind of trick
definitely the white or the Asian
because they're the most like respectful
and they be having a lot of money they
pay the best yeah yeah
Armenians are cool too
what emotions do you go through this
work
does it depress you or do you no I
always wanted to be a prostitute like I
would play GTA and I would say the
pastors of that oh my God I want to do
that when I grow up
and like I always wanted to like pay a
pimp and all that type of [__] is it so
you see it as a glamorous lifestyle
I mean for me because I always wanted to
do this like
since I was a kid
was there ever anything else you wanted
to do or this was it
no I wanted to do this this is your this
is your whole yeah or like I was
thinking about shipping but I'm too shy
to be a stripper like I can't get up and
dance within everybody
were there any role models in your life
what'd you mean like your stepmom or
older sister or anything like that
no
where do you stay now are you in motels
or
um
I move around
what makes you happy
a lot of things
money
what's your idea of success
um I'm not sure
do you have a temp now
I prefer not to answer
no I don't have a pimp okay
okay what was the best example of a
loving relationship oh what of a loving
relationship you saw between
a male and a female like
or a woman and a woman
um I don't know I don't have one your
dad and your stepmom
um how is their relationship it was
normal like normal married couple
was your relationship like with your dad
oh he was like hella strict like I like
I couldn't go outside much this is super
strict so and I didn't like that so I
would try and sneak out yeah
does he know you're doing this for for
work now I'm pretty sure because I'll be
getting tickets and it gets sent to
um badges
you begin what I get tickets and it gets
sent to their address oh I see
like uh what kind of tickets do you get
there there's like walking in the
loitering or whatever you call it yeah
I'm pretty sure they know
does this build up your self-esteem or
knock it down work in the streets sounds
like it builds it up
yeah definitely having all these guys
roll up and tell you how gorgeous you
are
yeah I think it'll build anybody's
self-esteem or
how do you think it's changed you since
you've been doing it definitely way more
confident way more confident
like I was super shy before I started
doing this and now I'm more open I'm
still a little bit shy though
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that do this kind
of work
that they people think we're like
depressed or don't want to do this or
yeah you're actually enjoy yeah
do you think you're getting addicted to
this lifestyle
the fast money and all that
I don't know what you mean addicted like
I chose to do it because I always wanted
to do it so it's like anybody else
choosing like
what they want to do there's no way you
could
stop and go do it oh no a regular square
job no
why would I do that and I always wanted
to do this yeah I know and you're making
money at it too I assume
how much were you making in a day or a
night
um I prefer not to answer okay
you've been in love before
no I never had a boyfriend
your friends
um I got like yeah
Associates are friends I got friends you
do
so when I
a guy rolls up to you put in a car
you'll have some interaction you'll talk
to him he'll talk to you do you ever
turn him down
like if they don't have the amount of
money that I want or if I just get a
weird feeling we feel like they might be
a cop or something like that yeah
or they act weird
you get guys asking for
like risky requests without a condom
stuff like that
what do you tell them
no did you say no
what kind of things have you learned
since you've been working the street
alive
um
I don't feel like going all over it
I'm sorry I don't feel like explaining
everything is a lot
are there any negative effects from
doing this kind of work
nothing
it's all good for you it doesn't affect
your karma doesn't affect anything like
that I think your karma
do you believe in karma
no no already
so it sounds to me like you have no
no regrets about doing this
you just you just want to keep at it and
what's your goal and thank you everybody
to be in five years
um
a few businesses
multiple sources of income like a big
only fans
type thing
you're made for this kind of work it
seems
yeah I always wanted to do it so
they're all younger than me yeah good
yeah
did you kind of run away from home
oh I just left like me and my dad got
into an argument when I was 17 and he
was like you can get out so I got out I
never went back I went to my grandma's
house and then I stayed there for like a
month and then came to L.A
you like L.A
it is cool
I like the blades out here all the
streets yeah
do you work all night or all day or it
depends really yeah yeah there's not
like a set it's good
you see yourself traveling traveling to
other cities oh yeah yeah
I worked in Florida before oh yeah
yeah what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned so far in
your 20 years
is this thing is called walk by faith
and not by sight
walk my way walk by faith and not by
sight
you get it yeah
all right Kat thank you so much for
sharing your story
be safe out there
oh we did now we're done yes I'm sorry
I'm hella awkward